[Music]
why am I in the morgue because you're
dead no I'm not
well the certificate here says that
you're dead so if you have one that says
that you're not I'd love to see it I
don't have any certificates and I know
the hell you're talking about man I'm
not dead
well maybe you're a zombie do I look
like a zombie terrible skin bloated
yellow teeth bags under your eyes shall
I go on
okay I'm certainly not dressed for the
prom but I'm talking to you can
zombies do that they talk in Night of
the Living Dead oh shut the up I
could not believe I'm having this
conversation
look my skin's not falling off okay I'm
not a zombie well Nicholas Hoult skin
doesn't fall off in warm bodies and he
talks in that one too
that's not canon if you think I'm a
zombie aren't you afraid I'm gonna come
over there by your neck I can
outrun a zombie what if I was one of
those fast running World War Z zombies
oh you're a fast
you're a fast world Rosie have you seen
your own body have you seen your own fat
human body I probably a slim chance of
that Oh God so matter with your leg
zombie my legs are asleep it's gonna
bite you
bloody so you want me to turn around and
then you can bite my neck
[Music]
you